monsieur chaperon vous étiez au deuxième
tour dans ce canton de trevière vous
êtes battus
42% des suffrages quel est votre
réaction ce soir écoutez ma première
réaction je ferai comme tout les hommes
politiques je remercierai mes électeurs
qui ont quand même voté à 42,17 % pour
moi et ma réaction sans faire de langue
de bois vous dire que je suis pas déçu
de pas avoir été élu évidemment on va
pas être débile en revanche je considère
quand même que 42 17% des voix pour nous
dans une élection à deux tours c'est
quand même pas négligeable et nous
étions je vous le rappelle seul contre
tous parce que Monsieur soir monsieur
Richard il n'est pas il est l'élu
peut-être de l'UMP de l'UDI des divers
droites il est élu du Parti socialiste
du Parti communiste enfin il élu tout le
monde j'estime si vous voulez qu'avec 42
17% des voix seules c'est quand même un
excellent un très grand résultat pour
nous très grands résultats c'est
prometteur écoutez je souhaite
évidemment que ce soit prometteur de
toute façon le combat continue et nous
nous serons toujours là pour défendre
nos idées et nous avons nos idées voilà
et les autres eux n'ont plus d'idées ils
sont plus d'idées puisqu'ils sont
obligés de se mettre tous ensemble pour
nous battre